depuis ce chantier la vue est imprenable
à saint laurent il a fallu moins d'un an
au futur casino pour sortir de terre le
cadre est atypique mais c'était bien la
volonté des investisseurs
nous on aime bien construire sur des
territoires qui sont atypiques
ici on est dans une région qui est
magnifique avec des points de vue
absolument incroyable c'est la raison
pour laquelle nous avons construit un
casino très vitre et pour faire profiter
nos clients d'une vue absolument
incroyable sur surtout de cette belle
nature un appel d'offres lancé il y a
des années un premier projet avorté le
futur casino a bien failli ne jamais
voir le jour
finalement le résultat est bien là avec
une cinquantaine de nouveaux emplois à
la clé dans la commune ont commencé une
phase de recrutement
c'est c'est très bien enfin moi je me
réjouis vraiment de cette opportunité
pour saint laurent pour la population
pour c'est vraiment un vrai plus
habitants et commerçants de saint
laurent sont quasi unanimes le casino
devrait permettre de relancer l'activité
dans le secteur en tant que commerçant
ça va nous attire un peu plus de monde
aura une offre pour le tourisme local
qui sera beaucoup plus étoffé là autour
il n'y a pas grand grand chose alors
éventuellement le bowling le ce bord là
mais à côté la région en train de mourir
à petit feu quoi ya pas mal de gens
d'ici qui aime bien jouer au casino
comme ça donc ça peut être un bon projet
le chantier dans les temps et la
direction promet une ouverture avant les
fêtes de fin d'année en attendant les
amateurs de jeux devront encore se
tourner vers salins les bains ou lons le
saunier